hello and welcome my name is Daniel
Kaffee I'm an assistant professor at
University of Massachusetts Medical
School in the Department of Medicine so
first off I'd like to thank the
organizers for the opportunity to
present so my work and secondly I'd like
to encourage you to submit your
questions during your presentation that
way I can answer them in the order that
they appear at the end of the
presentation so today I'm going to talk
about the evolution of Elune elements in
long non-coding RNA and message or an a
so my outline is as follows first I'm
going to provide some relevant
background link RNA and hello other
elements I'll also provide some
background on the data sets that are
used in this analysis and then I'll talk
about some of our results so I'll
describe two frequency and occurrence of
a low elements in linked RNA and
messenger RNA we'll also talk about the
location and orientation other elements
in link RNA messenger RNA will also
describe at the depletion of dimeric
other elements innate or na and related
to this sequence conservation of dimeric
and mana merrick other elements in these
different types of transcripts and
finally I'll talk about how link RNA
with dimeric a low alleys are enriched
in the cytosol and then I'll wrap up by
just providing a brief summary and talk
about some of our next steps okay so
what are linked RNA so we know at least
seventy-five percent of the genome is
transcribed maybe even more maybe up to
ninety percent and we can probably
classify most of these as long
non-coding RNAs and that's a very sort
of rod categorization now as the name
implies long non-coding RNAs little or
no coding potential occasionally they
might encode for small peptides but by
and large and we're defying them as RNA
molecules that perform a particular type
of function now typically there
arbitrary defined as 200 paces or longer
they can be located in pretty much any
region of the genome some of them are
located in so-called intergenic regions
some are approximate to protein coding
genes some overlap with introns and
exons of other genes and in many cases
some of them have been found in regions
that have been associated with various
diseases in genome-wide Association
studies so in general you tend to see
about a two-fold enrichment of link RNA
is in indonesia as compared to assess
all but of course there are lots of
exceptions there half-lives tend to be a
little less than message rnas but again
there's a broad range of half-lives the
actual levels of RNA are quite low
compared to messages and this makes them
hard to discover and sequence and in
addition there often cell-specific and
so again this makes it quite hard to
discover them and in many cases they
tend to be species are played specific
so I'll get into some of these details
the next few slides because they're
quite relevant to in the houses and
results that I'm going to present today
alright so one way to classify late or
noise is based on the genome location
and so this schematic is actually taken
from a nice review by win and China and
in the first example we have a happy
sense long non-coding RNA in red and
then we see it's coding coding gene
above it and so in this example here you
can see some of the actions of the link
RNA overlap with exons of a protein
coding gene whereas others overlap with
entrance I think by and large at least
what I see when gazing at the gym is
that in general you're going to see more
overlap or link or na exons with
entrance but you know every case
individual case is different so the
second class is intronic
lancor days and these are situations
where you've got a long non-coding RNA
that's found in the intron of a protein
coding gene and so this is also going to
be quite common in higher organisms such
as humans and primates where you have
relatively long introns and then the
third case is or you have back-to-back
divergently transcribed link RNA a
messenger RNA pairs so basically
basically to fight crime on translated
regions are back-to-back and you get the
Virgin's and often co transcription of
these two genes and then the final
example shown here is so-called
intergenic flung non-coding RNA now
given the fact that you know anywhere
between 75 and maybe ninety percent of
the genomes transcribed the concept of
intergenic it's becoming slightly
obsolete and of course the link or na
itself is genic but nevertheless this is
a useful way to think about NATO RNA and
it's certainly a very popular way to
think about them of course I think it's
useful to think about how close a
particular link RNA is to a protein for
the gene because that can have
organizations in terms of function and
so forth these are sort of just
simplified examples and reality there's
only be lots of variations and
combinations of these examples shown
here so for example divergently
transcribed transcripts can often
overlap at the five prime end
back to those diversity transcribed into
RNA messenger RNA pairs so this is a
figure taken from sakova and young and
basically they used gross seek so a
technique to analyze nascent transcripts
in embryonic stem cells before and after
a character pronunciation and so the
first two pounds in D and E they show
examples for two different link RNA
messenger RNA pairs so the first on the
left is the gotta six protein coding
gene and its neighboring main core na
and you can see after differentiation
you see coexpression of both of those
jeans similarly in the second example
for hx5 protein coding gene and its
neighboring link or na you see
expression of both transcripts following
differentiation so the example on the
left is more typical in the sense that
in general the link RNA tends to be
expressed at lower levels than the
message and then finally in the right
hand column they summarize I think it's
almost 700 link or name is turning Paris
and demonstrate that you effectively
have Co regulation of his transcripts so
basically can envisage a situation where
you have nor any blu rays you get
transcription in both directions at the
same time so natural antisense
transcripts are n 80s can they
regardless so class hlink' RNA and that
are anti sense to another gene so the
simplest type is the sis n 80 so they're
going to be transcribed from the
opposite strand of the protein coding or
non coding gene then perhaps a slightly
more interesting case or category is the
trans n 80 and so in this situation the
transcript is going to complimentary to
a gene on a different genomic location
so for example different chromosome or a
different stretch of the same chromosome
and so this is obviously a potential
interest because it probably involves
some gene duplication event
perhaps one of the duplicates becomes
sue genes of degenerates into gene well
at the same time still maintaining
complementarity to part of the other
duplication and so in terms of functions
some of these n 80s have the potential
or ability to form duplexes and our
products for generation of endogenous SI
RNA which can go off and perform as I or
any like functions and but other I get
better order a natural antisense behave
more like more traditional link on a so
they might interact with rather than you
keep proteins and regulate transcription
and so forth okay so this here is some
work from if it's sturla but also my
group and here we have macrophages from
bone marrow and mouse bone marrow and
the cells have been stimulated with a
LPS mimic which activates the tale or
two receptor and in turn that induces
expression of lots of immune genes so on
the inner track what we have is full
change values for protein coding genes
and the red jeans show induction of
known and you do so you get a massive
immune response in response to this LPS
mimic what's interesting is if you look
at the middle track you'll see induction
of lots of long non-coding RNA he knows
the full change values are smaller than
the protein coding genes and this is in
line with the fact that the expression
levels are lower house I already
mentioned and also you may notice that
many of the induced think RNA are in
regions where you also have induction of
protein coding genes and this
observation has also been shown in other
cell types so i think cancer for example
and then finally I just like to
highlight that one of the link or name
is highlighted here is link or na Cox
to this particular length RNA regulates
expression of several hundred immune
genes and so paper and science just came
out if you're interested in reading more
about that okay so as I mentioned before
many link rnase our species or clade
specific so this work is from the
gencode project and so on the left
column you have human lung o human long
non-coding RNAs into gentle database and
what they're doing is assessing whether
or not they have a homologue in the
various other species in each of the
individual compounds so what you'll see
here is there's lots of green in the
left-most columns and so that
corresponds primarily to homologous long
non-coding RNAs in crime eights but then
to the right where we're looking at cows
and rodents you see a lot more red
indicating that no homologous link RNA
was detected and so there might be a few
potential reasons for this so the first
thing that obviously because there's no
coding region you don't have the same
level of evolution constraint so might
just be harder to detect homologs
related to that it could also be that
you can envisage a situation where long
ornate molecules can conserve a
secondary structure or molecular
function but don't necessarily conserve
their sequences and thirdly and relates
to this talk it's also possible that the
presence of repetitive elements
particularly those that our primate
specific will make it harder to actually
detect homologs in these other species
ok so in terms
of molecular functions Nikolai perform
quite a lot of different functions are
at least a lot of being determined today
and so this is taken from another review
and so in the first example here we have
a link or natives essentially acting as
a decoy transcription factor that
typically recognizes a specific sequence
in the DNA and regulates transcription
and here the later egg has a similar
sequence it is able to buy the
transcription factor and essentially act
as a decoy and repressed function of the
transcription factor in the second
example we have a link or RNA which has
planning sites for SI or micro RNA and
it essentially acts as a sponge that
mops up these various micro or native
with otherwise target various messenger
ornate and so does it arresting at least
one an interesting example where a
duplicated gene becomes are degenerates
into sushi gene and in turn performs
this kind of function in the third
example and often a quite common
mechanism is where the link RNA binds
and forms a ribonucleoprotein complex
and this goes on to two things like
regulate transcription and so forth then
related to this is a situation where
link rnase can find various chromatin
modifiers and again DS can alter
transcription of genes and so forth and
then the final example sulfide through
seven and these this captures various
situations where a link or na interacts
with a messenger RNA and it can either
alter translation it can alter splicing
or in some cases that can bind it
through priming to your and that in turn
can lead to degradation the message so
hello elements were discovered way back
in nineteen seventy nine in humans there
dimeric sort of meaning they have two
arms or two monomers and these are
homologous to the 7sl or na
and now in Romans it's it's different
basically there's a big it's called be
one and this related element has a
single arm or monomer that is homologous
to 7 s 07 SL RNA so the others combined
SRP nine and SRP 14 or more complex
above a poly a binding protein they
depend on another repeater valve element
called line 14 cocky and so a key point
here is that these are by far the most
abundant transpose element Liam in
genome so we're talking about about a
million copies and eleven percent of the
genome and so despite this fact I think
many biologists including myself have
ignored them or dismissed them as junk
DNA but I think that's gradually
changing but yeah the very least I think
most people consider them a
bioinformatic nuisance typically when we
search our sequence reads against a
reference genome we typically use a
version of the reference genome where
the repetitive elements have been or
other elements for that matter have been
massive because it's just too hard to
knock two unique regions so as I said
our attitude towards our elements is
gradually changing there's a growing
list of excitations and so what I mean
by that is several of these alo elements
have been repurposed to perform various
molecular functions this is by no means
an exhaustive list but it certainly
gives you a taste for the types of
things and functions that Islands
helmets can perform those that are
particularly relevant to this
presentation are towards the end so for
example others in the 500 years of a
potential to regulate translation so
just some situations in zinc fingers for
example zinc finger genes were you see
these albums in the 500 meter and
downregulates translation also there's
cases where inverted others can be bound
by the a DA or enzyme can walk which is
involved in RNA editing and this can
lead to nuclear attention
and then related to that some inverted
values in the three grunting to yours of
messages combined stuff and on this in
turn can affect whether or not the RNA
is located in the nucleus or not then in
the last example which I'll also expand
on later you can have situations where
link rnase contain partial values and
these in turn combined stuff and I need
to stuff immediate decay of messages
okay so here's a nice figure describing
the evolution of alloy elements what you
see here is first off down the bottom
you have this kind of Tanner brown
background and that corresponds to the
Mon America face this is prior to the
speciation or emergence of primates so
here we just have our elements in
progenitor species where it's a single
marmar or a single arm and ending in the
green background we see the emergence of
primates and the corresponding emergence
of the dye marriage LOL man so al
elements that contain the two arms and
so first and we had the s and the Jason
families evolved and they later on the Y
sub families or the young saffolix
evolves in various primates such as
human and gorillas so why should we look
at repetitive elements and Link our RNA
and why should we even care so aside
from the various functions that have
been elucidated in various others that
I've represented so far more recently
it's been shown that these atoms perform
or have potentially perform functions
and Link or any sort of the one example
includes these half SBS think RNA so
these link rnase contained elements
which contain a stuffin binding site or
half of the stuff flying sites so
basically the partial alloy elements in
the link RNA is complementary to other
partial a little elements that require
me to your messages it's hybridized and
once they hybridize and the stuff and
poking combined and this in turn leads
to stuff
okay so the second example of a
repetitive heldman performing a function
in length rnases shown here I apologize
I emitted the citation but basically you
have a protein coding gene called uch l
1 it also has an antisense link or neg
called a s uch l 1 you can see there's
some overlap of complementarity between
some of the exons and what this
antisense link RNA does is regulate the
protein levels of uch l 1 and this
function is very much dependent on the
existence or presence of the sine B 2
element and also its orientation so in
addition stones two examples two papers
have just recently come out showing that
repetitive elements are ubiquitous in
long non-coding RNAs in the first paper
they focused on the curve H repaired of
element that show that it's very much
biased towards the five prime and and
this is associated with or correlated
with sm stem cell specific expression
and then in the second paper again they
showed that repetitive elements were
ubiquitous and long non-coding RNAs and
similarly they showed their words a five
prime end positional bias and related to
this there seemed to be an association
with sis regulations so basically the
hypothesis our proposed proposed
recommend mechanism is the repetitive
elements are involved in sis regulation
of the link rnase transcription in
addition it's worth noting that several
link RNAs that are well characterized
and have clear molecular functions
contain repetitive elements so I
apologize this I guess some of the
labels became pics latent in the file
conversion
anyway in the top example we have the
exon structure of link ornate costume
and the horizontal lines below indicate
that there's two repetitive elements on
the three prime and then a second
example we have Nick rnap 21 which is
involved in regression of genes involved
in p3 a pathway and here you can see in
the second exon there's various
repetitive elements scattered throughout
the sequence and in the tour example
we've got a link RNA called anchor in
this case the last excellence of the
three prime and contains in fairly large
repetitive development this here is just
showing two additional examples where
characterized think Renee's were you
have lots of repetitive relatively small
repetitive elements scattered across the
entire sequence okay so moving on to
some of our analysis and results for all
elements so most of this and out of our
analysis focuses or uses the version 68
of the ensemble genome we focus on the
spliced transcripts runner down the
unspliced ones and for computational
analysis we focus on a non redundant set
of transcripts and so what I mean by
that is we take the canonical or
economical transcript for any particular
gene and the intention here is to reduce
the likelihood of incorporating any and
biases into the analysis so for example
if we if it was the case that some links
were over-represented and had lots of
splice variants they might somehow
introduce supplies and then for the
expression analysis that it's right last
we actually look at all splice variants
and we do this because well so it's it
and to perform stuff analysis you read
be as inclusive as possible because and
a lot of things just aren't expressed in
many cell types so 14 ounces I'll often
compare linked rnase and messenger RNAs
to intergenic sequences and these will
be sized much to the link or neighs or
the messenger RNAs and the reason we do
this is because there's differences in
size between messenger RNAs and the
internet so you can see from these
distributions here that messenger RNAs
are longer linked our days so messages
are purple and link or nazar green and
this is even true if you just look at
the untranslated regions of messenger
RNA they tend to be slightly longer than
link or name but despite despite the
fact that link or and I tend to be
shorter than messages even if you look
at the actual relative composition of
link rnase and repetitive elements in
them you can see even the longer linked
rnase tend to have a greater fraction of
repetitive element in them so you can
see towards the right in the top panel
and there's still a fair amount of red
and yellow and green which ranges from
50 percent to 100 sent repetitive albums
whereas a messenger RNA you don't see
this now obviously messenger RNA contain
a lot of coding regions and these won't
have a pair of elements but bear in mind
the you to yours will are actually
slightly longer than the links okay so
if we compare messenger RNA to link or
na what we see is that most messenger
RNA actually lack other elements are
depleted relative to antigenic sequences
regardless of the size of those
intergenic sequences this is also true
so it has bested Renee are depleted well
to make RNA thank you for and so if you
look at the grenades you've got about 20
about 23% of the links actually contain
at least one other element which is
slightly less than the size match
antigenic sequences so if we look
chromosome x chromosome what we see is
the percent of transcripts within a loop
and messages is generally low
than that found in Mingora as well in
general as you go from left to right the
percentage is decreasing and that is in
part because we're decreasing the size
of the chromosomes water moving towards
smaller chromosomes that the one
interesting exception is chromosome 19
where you see a sort of a a reversal in
the situation basically see an
enrichment of other elements in the
messages and so various different papers
in the literature suggested a possible
explanation for this when taken together
so if you look at the vendor genome
paper you'll see that I'm so that's a
top out you'll see that it's chromosome
19 is enriched in protein coding genes
and it's also original elements also in
the lander genome paper they showed
pretty much the same thing to show that
chromosome 19 is enriched nalo elements
then in the bottom right-hand corner
this is a figure for chromosome 19 and
here and in the bottom section of the
figure there's these brown blocks which
correspond to gene families that have
undergone significant change
applications within chromosome 19 so if
we take out that together you might form
the hypothesis that the enrichment of a
little elements in chromosome 19 is
somehow associated with the duplication
of messages within this chromosome 19 so
here we're looking at messages Oni no
link or nay so now that we're looking at
messages that contain a little elements
and on the right we're looking at
messages that contain that do not
contain other elements and so the colors
correspond to diffraction transcripts
that either have an intra chromosomal
paralog and inter chromosomal parallel
or no para log at all and so across the
different chromosomes by and large most
of them are quite similar one of the
exceptions is again chromosome 19 so
that's marked by the arrows and so here
what you can see is in
the messages that contain yellow you
have an enrichment or a lot more
intrachromosomal paralogs compared to
those messages that lock lives so in
other words what this suggests is that
basically in chromosome 19 you probably
had a bunch of protein coding genes that
contained alloy elements in their beauty
ours and these duplicates or the entire
gene plus teachers educated many times
and this cave provides to so many album
containing messages on chromosome 19 so
if we focus just on transcripts that
contain repeats and we look at the
proportion of the different repetitive
elements we see a slightly different
picture so on the right here you see
that messages about thirty five percent
of the repetitive elements and messages
are elements and so they're other
elements are enriched and repeat
containing messenger RNA compared to the
different intergenic sequences which are
pretty much twenty-three percent across
the board and also their enriched
relative to the core network it's only
nineteen percent so this is slightly
tempted to the first but we're beginning
to understand this and hopefully the
next few slides will explain that okay
so if we look at orientation hello
elements and link or link RNA we can see
a stronger preference for the reverse
oriented other elements compared to
messages or intergenic sequences where
it's about fifty percent and also if we
look at reverse oriented other elements
and make rnase we see most them lack a
poly a signal so that's shown in the
bottom left-hand panel so you see the
green there correspond stills reverse
out our elements are they all lack the
poly a signal also you'll notice that
they are a lot further
from the three prime end sequence so
that was a hint as to what's going on
here and that prompt us to see whether
or not there was a positional bias in
the other elements so to do this
basically all of your transcripts are
different sizes and so what we do is we
divide molecules into 100 uniformly
spaced pins so in this example the first
sequence has 900 Yuka tights so we're
going to have a hundred pins of size
nine in the second example we've 1280
tights so that's 100 pairs of size 12
and so we can do that in this a toy
example here is we can just count the
number of transcripts for each bin that
having a hollow and so here in this
pretend example you can see at positions
34 through 50 there's two transcripts to
contain out on us at those respective
bins so we can apply this technique to
our data set so if we look at the
reverse oriented others what we see here
is that link rnase have a fairly central
or even distribution of reverse oranges
repetitive elements whereas the message
RNA tents tend to have reverse oriented
how elements towards the three prime end
in contrast if we look at the fort
oriented I lose these tend to be towards
the tree pine prime end in both link
rnase and message are they consistent
with this if we look at exxon structure
what we see is there's a depletion of
the Ford oriented others in the internal
exons or to put us another way we see
more of the reverse oriented out of
elements in the internal accents so in
particular if you break it down by what
are not there dimeric others or just
correspond to letters or right arms what
you see is the left and right arms tend
to be reverse oriented in the internal
axons and in addition they can't be
complete axon suggesting that there's
some form of x XM ization going on and
also maybe there's certain splice
variants to perform certain functions
under certain
conditions we perform the same analysis
for messages as you might expect you
don't see a whole lot of aloe elements
the internal exons because they'll
correspond what to coding regions for
the most part but in the rare cases
where they do exist internal exons
they're going to be reversed oriented as
well so putting all this together we can
explain it as follows basically you've
got these a little elements you've got a
left monomer on a right monomer and
close by to both of our DS poly a
signals in the forward orientation and
so in message RNA and Link RNA the
forward oriented others tend to be
towards the 3 prime end because you know
this is ok probably ventilation is okay
towards the 3 prime end whereas in link
RNA you also see lots of the reverse
oriented all elements and easily more
evenly dispersed because they're less
likely to encode a poly a signal so next
we looked at the length distribution of
different repetitive elements and so the
right here we've got messages and the
other elements are LED and so what you
see is a clear bimodal distribution for
the red alleys and so the first peak
corresponds to shorter LOL ins and the
second peak corresponds to longer
full-length values and so you see more
of the same bimodal distribution in the
second row where we're looking at
various intergenic sequences however if
you look at the link or a plot on the
left side what you see is the bimodal
distribution is slightly different you
still see the two peaks but we can see
is a depletion of those four lengths
others so if you look more closely at
the region basically what we see is that
those shorter values correspond to the
left and right arms and that's true for
go to lengths or na and a message RNA
and as you might expect the longer
sequences corresponds to die Marik
alleys but the key point here is that
you've got less at the diner Kylie's in
the main Renee's compared to the
messages and so that's also captured
here in as pie where the dimeric others
are cleared read and you can see a
depletion in the links compared to the
messages or the other antigenic
sequences so if we break it down by the
different subfamilies that i described
so on the top row we've got link rnase
in the middle road got messages and then
the bottom row we've got intergenic
sequences and the comms corresponds to
different types of others we've got the
diner the left right and those are fall
into the other category and so you can
see regardless of whether it's a link or
na a message for an antigenic that died
America is in the left home are
primarily the S sub family and so
consistent with this when we look at
each of different RNA types we see that
the lake rnase have a depletion of the S
sub family relative to messages or
indeed intergenic sequences so given the
fact that we saw a depletion in the
dimeric a lose it looked like maybe
there was some kind of negative
selection of these dimeric elders and
NATO RNA and so it made sense to look at
conservation of these different other
types across link or days and messages
and so what we saw for the dimeric Oz is
that they were more conserving the
messages compared to make RNA or
intergenic whereas the left and right
arms didn't have the same pattern so
again just sort of adds additional
evidence to the possibility that there's
some kind of negative selection going on
we look more closely at the percent
identities of these different LOL
moments it becomes apparent that
the increased the increase in percent
identity in the messages can be
primarily attributed to the s and J sub
Tommy so in the bottom row here in the
first time we've got our dimeric aliens
for messages you can see a shift in to
the right and percent identities for the
blue and red compared to those in link
or na and intergenic so that ship is
indicated by the dashed lines so giving
all this information started to look at
a recent code that essentially the
encode project published paper showing
that most messages as you expect most
message or na are found in this is all
but when you look at the nuclear and
cytosolic fractions link arrays tend to
be more enriched in the nucleus compared
to messages so we decided to look at
these different cell types in the
context of our data to see if through
some kind of relationship and so here on
the Left we have linked our days and on
the right we have message RNA and so
transcripts are divided into four
categories so the first category in red
corresponds to transcripts for you how
they complete a lonely next we have
transcripts where they just contain a
left a little only and then we've not a
category where the transcripts just
contain a right hello and then the final
category is where the transcripts don't
contain any repetitive elements now
regardless of what what are you looking
at link or nazar messages when you're
looking across just six different cells
most of the transcripts aren't gonna be
expressed and that's going to
essentially eighty percent of the data
however what's very interesting is if
you look at the link or n a lot on the
left what you see is most of the link
RNAs that contain our significant
portion of the link our needs to contain
just complete auto are enriched in the
site itself indeed Ian if you look at
messages which are obviously exported to
the Sun itself you still see the case
where these
messages with a complete a low occur
higher levels in Addis I saw so clearly
it is some kind of relationship between
the presence of a dimeric or complete a
low you know transcript and its levels
its expression levels in the cytosol ok
so to summarize we've seen that there's
a greater proportion if link RNAs that
contain one or more ellos than messages
exception is chromosome 19 and we can
primarily attributed cubic ation events
of a region where the messages already
contained lots of all elements we look
just at the repeat containing
transcripts first thing we saw is
there's a clear bias in terms of the
reverse oriented others or perhaps the
most interesting observation is the
depletion of the dimeric islands from
link or neighs and so this is associated
also with the depletion of the lof
subfamily in the chorus and also the
fact that it's also associated with the
fact that link horns with East America
out I lose tend to be enriched in a set
us off so in terms of next steps and
we're now currently investigating at why
the presence of these dimeric I lose
leads to or is associated with increased
levels of expression in the cytosol or
it's a few
I would like to acknowledge first I'd
like to acknowledge the efforts of Dan
ILO and Adam West pies are my group and
also the Fitzgerald lab so we've had a
lot of fun collaborating with Susan in
NJ and Kate in terms of looking at the
evolution and function of Mingora days
Indian eight immune response and so
finally I think at this point if you
bear with me I can reduce questions and
hopefully respond to them so there's a
question if the yellow element are
enriched in the link rnase is there any
normalization to account for abundance
of these compared two lines or
repetitive sequence I'm not sure I
completely follow the question but I
think the answer is no we have not done
that so it says if there is no Polly a
signal these will not let you be reverse
transcribed by l1 so put this somehow
read later trans effect of l1 or tea on
the frequency of a little integration
and so yeah this is a fair comment
certainly possible but we certainly
don't have an answer to dash so one
question asked what does what role does
those these atoms in link or name
machinery play and disease so it's very
early days and I don't think we really
know so those have been implicated in
in other contexts I don't know if there
are always messages but in terms of
length or ends it's very early days I'm
just beginning to understand things and
so there's another question which I
unfortunately don't think I could answer
so there appears to be one non homologue
detected across all species what species
is the reference I guess I could go back
and look and so I think that's bloody
puss ok so if there's no more questions
i think is a good time to wrap up I'd
like to thank you for joining me and
hopefully I'll see you again soon thank
you